a gritos de svetlana presidenta así
iniciaron las manifestaciones de este
sábado en belarús desde hace casi dos
meses el país vive una manifestación
tras otra después de la discutida
reelección del presidente alexander
lukashenko al poder durante 26 años
contra el oponente
svetlana tica nos calla hoy refugiada en
lituania como en todas las protestas la
policía está deteniendo masivamente y
como todos los sábados las mujeres están
en el frente de la batalla en una
entrevista de manuel mckeown dijo que
estas mujeres imponen respeto
el presidente francesa ni a de lo que
pasa en belarús es una crisis de poder
un poder autoritario que no logra
aceptar la lógica democrática y que se
agarra con fuerza
está claro que lukashenko tiene que
marcharse en naciones unidas donde sigue
la asamblea general
suecia expresó su temor y el de sitges y
hasta la armada por la situación en
belarús tras las elecciones del 9 de
agosto que no fueron ni libres ni justas
ni del frío
en la misma tribuna belarús acusó a
occidente de injerencia y yo voy a este
año la realidad no son más que intentos
de sembrar el caos y la anarquía en
nuestro país para hacer que belarús
pierda muchos años de desarrollo de
varus mejoras bichi no llevo demasiado
emanuel mac con viajara a letonia y
lituania a partir del lunes dos países
europeos fronterizos con belarús según
el elíseo no se excluye que se reúna con
su plan ática nos calla